last year a little man stepped up here
to take an Oscar but having performed a
miracle on 34th Street he said at that
time that he believed in Santa Claus
nobody doubted it tonight he will
present the award for the best
performance by an actress in Actress in
a supporting role and I am sure he will
have very little trouble convincing the
later lady that she too should believe
in Santa Claus I give you everybody's
favorite Kris Kringle mr. Edmund
getting no reindeer what you to Bob oh
you know what the holidays over I was
just reaching the point where I could
venture down the street without being
accosted by a mob of small children but
seriously I do believe still in Santa
Claus and now I'm privileged to present
this high award don't forget that his
performances like these that make movie
audiences believe in him to the ladies
who've been nominated for the Best
Performance by an actress in a
supporting role are Barbara Bel Geddes
in I remember mama RKO radio Ellen
corbeil also when I remember mama RKO
radio agnes moorehead in Johnny Belinda
Warner Brothers Jean Simmons in Hamlet J
Arthur rank Two Cities film universal
international British Claire Trevor in
Key Largo Warner Brothers and the winner
ladies and gentlemen the winner is
Claire Trevor
I just want to say bottom of my heart
this is one of the happiest moments of
my life and also that I have three boys
I hope they grow up to be directors or
writers so that they can give their old
lady a job I loved my husband who gave
me such encouragement thank you
Thank You mr. Santa Claus